in other news the Minneapolis police
officer who shot and killed an unarmed
Australian yoga teacher refuses to talk
about the deadly encounter
investigators say Muhammad nor has
declined to be interviewed about the
death of Justine diamond but the officer
with him Saturday night is talking
Matthew harity told investigators
yesterday he was startled by a loud
sound seconds before the shooting
outrage is growing in Damon's native
country people gathered this morning on
a Sydney beach for a vigil Australia's
Prime Minister is demanding answers
Jamie yuccas is outside the Minneapolis
Police Headquarters this morning Jamie
good morning to you good morning the
officers body cameras and squad car
camera were not turned on during the
time of this incident amid growing
pressure for new information the
Minnesota Bureau of Criminal
Apprehension held a press conference
here last night where they did release
new details we now know that officer
noir has not come forward to be
interviewed and the state cannot make
him talk it's frustrating to have some
of the picture but not all of it we
cannot compel officer nor to make a
statement I wish we could minnesota
investigators say a loud noise startled
officer muhammad Knorr partner just
before noir shot and killed Justine
Damon a well-liked yoga instructor and
life coach where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
according to the Minnesota Bureau of
Criminal Apprehension Damon called 911
assault Saturday night nor an officer
Matthew harity drove down an alley
behind Damon's house with their squad
car lights off searching for a suspect
harity told investigators they were
startled by a loud bang immediately
after Damon approached the driver's side
of the cruiser officer nor shot Damon
from the front passenger seat seeing
someone from our community in the police
department was something that milestone
and something we all appreciated
activists sued ohlawd says Minneapolis
is Somali community at
nor when he joined the police department
in 2015 but since joining nor has had
three complaints filed against him two
are pending
the third was dismissed without
discipline and last month nor and two
other officers were sued for false
imprisonment assault battery and
negligence for their alleged conduct
during a welfare check and we're
desperate for information
Damon's family here in Minneapolis and
in her native Australia have begged for
information surrounding her death we are
seeking answers to this this is a
shocking killing it is it's inexplicable
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull is now joining their fight
our hearts go out to her family I mean
how can a woman out in the street in her
pajamas seeking assistance from the
police be shot like that the city of
Minneapolis says it will release a
detailed transcript of the 911 once it's
reviewed and then shared with the family
now investigators want to talk to any
potential witnesses including a man on a
bicycle who stopped as officers were
attending to Daymond we did reach out to
officers NORs
attorney and we have not heard back at
this point Nora Murray Jamie thank you
so much